des sanctions qui ciblent directement le
président biélorusse 29 hauts
fonctionnaires sont également inscrits
sur ces listes noires ils font partie de
la commission électorale deux ministères
mais aussi des forces de l'ordre nous
envoyons le message que nous devons
faire davantage que simplement publier
des déclarations
nous devons également prendre des
mesures concrètes
nous nous attaquons aux violations des
droits de l'homme en biélorussie avec le
plus grand sérieux des sanctions
qualifié de pression contre-productive
par la diplomatie biélorusse qui a
promis une réponse adéquate aux pays
baltes
l'union européenne envisage également
d'interdire d'entrée sur son territoire
une vingtaine de fonctionnaires
biélorusses et de geler leurs avoirs
mais parmi les 27 pays de l'ue eux
certains craignent que des sanctions
directes contre alexandre loukachenko
n'anéantisse la possibilité d'une
médiation entre les autorités et
l'opposition
le président biélorusse qui de son côté
semble vouloir apaiser les tensions
il a évoqué l'idée d'un référendum
constitutionnel sur une réforme
judiciaire
malgré le fait que nous ayons un système
quelque peu autoritaire pour organiser
la vie publique
le président protège et défend néanmoins
les tribunaux et c'est un aspect
personnel et nous devons nous assurer
que le système fonctionne sans être liés
aux individus par conséquent je pense
que dans la nouvelle constitution nous
refléteront de manière adéquate le
système d'organisation de nos tribunaux
un référendum dont alexandre loukachenko
n'a précisé ni les modalités ni une date
potentielle mais qu'il avait déjà
évoquée dans le passé moscou l'avait
d'ailleurs qualifié de pistes
prometteuses pour sortir de la crise
depuis trois semaines la contestation
continue de gronder dans les bouts de
minsk dimanche l'opposition a rassemblé
des dizaines de milliers de personnes
dans la capitale
[Musique]